I want to jump to this story we had this
tweet from Alx breaking the Mind
Administration has officially filed a
notice of appeal in the Missouri V Biden
censorship case if their federal judge
issued a preliminary injunction order
barring government officials from
contacting social media companies to
suppress lawful speech
simply put this is the Biden
administration's notice of appeal
seeking to effectively overturn the
right of freedom of speech in this
country the First Amendment yes why the
judge said you are still allowed to
contact all of these companies for
issues of National Security and just not
for suppressing the speech of of U.S
citizens
the appeal specifically means the Biden
Administration wants the right to
suppress the speech of American citizens
this is where we're currently at the New
York Times takes the amazing approach
that uh
it's bad
we should allow the government to stop
people from speaking their minds that's
where we're currently at in this country
so you want to talk about a twisted
reality we have people who
here's where Democrats are they quite
literally don't care if people are
bringing into schools books depicting
adult carnal activities and this
information to kids they literally don't
care that a teacher was trying to give
students instruction or literally to
give students instruction how to use
Grindr
which is an 18 and up app only they
literally do not care of these things
they don't care that kids are getting
access to
psychotic and obscene graphic
pornography
I'm not just talking about as I
mentioned earlier like two two people in
a bedroom the stuff you can find online
is insane they don't care about any of
that what they don't want you to do is
criticize Joe Biden what they don't want
you to do is point out the hunter Biden
laptop story what they don't want you to
do is point out that they actually want
to censor conservatives because if you
do those things they try to remove you
what they don't want you to do is
Advocate that children's not get sex
change surgery they'll ban you for that
too
but they don't care about all the
depravity
when I look at this stuff with what Joe
Biden is doing
it really does feel like we are looking
at
an evil mirror image of what this
country and what our uh our society has
believed in it's the antithesis of
everything we thought was good and moral
and just we want people to speak their
minds we don't want kids exposed to
graphic images what are the Democrats
advocating for the complete inversion
the suppression of individual rights and
speech and they Advocate children see
these things and that's just that's
that's just the beginning we can go on
to all the seven deadly sins too this is
shockingly insane well this has been
going on for a long time this is the
most transparently it's been I guess
reflected in government but even if we
look at Twitter before Elon Musk the
amount of resources they were dedicating
to controlling the narrative on the
vaccine or election interference versus
the amount of resources they were
dedicated to actually you know shutting
down uh you know child exploitation
material it absolutely shows where their
priorities are they don't actually care
about people's well-being it's all about
controlling the narrative so you know
children being exposed to any type of
graphic thing being exploited online
that doesn't really harm their control
so they don't really do anything about
it but hey someone questioning the
efficacy of the facts that actually does
threaten their control so they they go
all in on devoting resources Manpower
finances whatever into controlling that
when you think of the government do you
think of it as a very powerful thing or
do you see it more as kind of like a
Visage of power I think I think it's a
very very powerful thing and I think
Americans are
they're naive as to how all Encompass
how all-encompassing the government
really is in their day-to-day lives
infringing on their freedoms I mean
because yes America is a very free
country especially compared to somewhere
like even you know Canada or the UK but
to act as if the country now resembles
anything the founding fathers had in
mind no they would they're rolling in
their graves right now I I agree that we
need some form of censorship and kind of
tail backing off what you were saying
about how kids are seeing like graphic
images like okay we need to protect some
aspect of our of our culture of our life
of our species and that is through just
censorship but I just want to ask you
one quick question real quick do you
conceive of preventing children from
seeing pornography as censorship
I suppose it depends on how it's done
that could be one way to prevent them
from seeing it to say like you can't be
here it is censorship well I mean
another way like hey let's go out and
play tonight instead of being on the
computer that's not really censorship
the way that I this is only my
perception when I can like think of
censorship I think of something that is
try at least the effort is made to
prevent anyone from seeing it so like
kids being prevented from seeing adult
content to me that doesn't come across a
censorship because you prevent kids from
grabbing the the red hot stove because
it's you know it's not it's protecting
them
censorship doesn't need to be like
always negative or always positive it's
just restricting information I think
ratings on movies are a form of
censorship to let you know ahead of time
don't take your kid to see the R-rated
one well I mean like courts in the US
have ruled that you like pornography is
not free speech so I I guess I would
push back on the idea that restricting
pornography is because if it doesn't
technically infringe on your free speech
because pornography isn't speech
according to the courts is that actually
censorship
I think censorship is oh we got the
suppression or prohibition of any parts
of books films news Etc that are
considered obscene politically
unacceptable or a threat to security
which is that's like a half definition
you can censor and and let things happen
like I can be like well I looked at the
video I'm the guy that owns the website
and I'm going to let the video on I
still censored it I just didn't take it
down I censored it and allowed it to be
there right so here's ultimately the
ultimately the issue
censorship based on that definition the
other simple definition was restricting
access to images information books Etc
that are offensive
we find it offensive to show kids this
lewd and lascivious stuff we would like
that to be censored
the left Democrats Etc and liberals want
kids to see these things which I think
is psychotic and evil so they say we
oppose censorship however your naughty
words where you say something like I
disagree with with you and the way you
you are living your life I think is bad
for everyone they say that is shocking
and offensive and shouldn't be allowed
let me just put it this way
these people live in this world
for you and I for the people who watch
this show
it would seem to be insanity
of course we are offended at the thought
that children are getting access to
lewdness of his behavior of course we
are shocked that people try to restrict
our ability to have a political debate
in the left World they are absolutely
shocked we would try and stop children
from seeing these things how insane is
that it is insane I've had friends be
like what why do you want censorship
censorship's bad don't do no no
censorship and it's like yeah snap out
of it yeah you want to censor the bad
stuff of course but then who's deciding
what's bad is it what he said it's what
she said someone what they said about my
kid like so who's censoring reality yeah
who's the who's the who's the sensor is
should we make it an algorithm like a an
open source artificial intelligence
that's giving advice to people this is
why it's a culture War because there are
two distinct moral Frameworks there is
the traditional American I would say
simply put judeo-christian moral
framework and then there is the leftist
there is no truth but Power moral
framework
it seems to be you know look it is
really simple in in some ways say a
thing and a leftist will say the exact
opposite for all the only reason of
opposing you
hence their positions change rapidly and
seem to make no sense
that that's just the reality of it well
there was a one of the crassenstein
brothers after that Viral clip of nudity
like exposed male genitalia I think it
was Seattle Pride one of them was
actually somewhat defending it and it's
like the there I can think of no other
reason why a sane person would be
defending a male exposure exposing
himself to minors if it were not a
leftist just contradicting the right
right and the crescentstein's for those
not familiar they're prominent liberal
personalities have tried taking this
more moderate Centrist approach and so
their approach to this was hey it's it's
it's probably not that big of a deal if
a kid sees nudity it happens a lot uh I
don't think someone should be writing
riding around nude in front of a bunch
of kids that's not a good thing but Libs
of tick tock sharing it is worse than
the guy doing it so it was still this
critique of Libs of tick tock that did
to a certain degree downplay the nudity
in front of kids I don't think it's
completely wrong for the crescents to
say that because kids go in locker rooms
all the time with with people who are
naked around them however her at an
event that is explicitly sexual in
nature with the intent of expressing
sexual like ideas then you're crossing a
line into grooming territory but my
point with the crescentsteins here to
add on to what you're saying is they're
just saying something critical of the
right for the sake of being critical of
the right it's this is the crazy thing
how hard would it be for any liberal to
say something like I want Universal
Health Care and then I go okay I have no
opinion on that what do you think about
these books yeah those books shouldn't
be for kids how hard is that they can't
do it they come on they come on the
culture War podcast or they come on this
show and they say something like I think
it's good and I'm like really why you
end up with that famous clip you end up
with a famous clip we had with Lance
from the serfs saying that women should
be allowed to get an abortion and
whenever they want but that pregnant
women shouldn't be allowed to do math
because it kills the baby right like
that's awesome because there's no moral
framework I think there are a lot of
people that would be considered on the
left or or you know liberal uh
culturally liberal that would be open to
talking exactly what you're saying Tim
like yeah okay uh universal healthcare
great this book probably shouldn't be
for kids great but it's the loudmouth
contrarians that are famous right now
and it's so annoying this tribalism is
like it's like binding it's like holding
people back like sticky goo on their
feet that they can't you can get out of
it but you got to realize you're kind of
left it's like all people too it's it's
everywhere I look man in this political
crap is like the willingness to say no
like
not always sometimes yes and yes you can
both be right you know sorry Phil were
you about to say something you look like
you're about to say something uh no just
uh Tim said that
um Tim was saying that talking about
Lance and and I think that you gave uh
Lance too much credit but what do you
mean because there's no moral framework
yeah you said that he has no moral no
moral framework and that's true but I
don't think that the reason that you
know Lance said that dumb thing was
because of a lack of moral framework I
think it was just because Lance was
tired after using all of his brain power
to keep up for for the the conversation
that was just Lance not knowing that he
was going to be walked into a uh well
this is round two is about to happen I I
I I've talked to a lot of people about
the idea of debates
it's the weirdest concept to me
you know like people have asked me like
I'm going to be debating this issue and
you know what do you think about this
argument I'm like do you believe what
you are saying like then what are you
asking me for if someone came here and
said did you know x y r z I'd be like I
didn't I'll look into it here's what I
believe like I don't it's this idea that
we're debating people just to appear
like we know what we're talking about
makes no sense to me so
I will have a conversation with quite
literally anybody and there is no
winning or losing a debate
between debate and dialectic like are we
talking to prove the other wrong or are
we talking because we are both
interested in pursuing the truth and we
maybe have different versions of what it
is and we're trying to kind of Spar back
and forth to see how we can best get
there those are two very different I
guess approaches to have and that's I'm
not I I'm not that interested in like
strictly debate because there are formal
debates like Point Counterpoint Point
Counterpoint I don't think that's
productive but when you actually have
people who are having a conversation and
they could have opposing views but
they're trying to understand each other
and arrive at the truth that I think is
actually something interesting so this
is what happens Lance from the Surfs
comes on the show with the intent of
winning a debate we have him on the show
with the intent of him explaining how he
sees the world yeah the problem is he
doesn't actually know how he sees the
world he just knows how to regurgitate
talking points for the sake of debate
hence when it comes to the question of
abortion I can ask him 50 million
questions on what his logic is and he
can't answer it because he doesn't have
any because his arguments to what you
might say he he has he has
pre-prescripted arguments he had it
written down I don't write anything down
people are like Tim you did a really
great job on on Rogan with Dorsey and
I'm like I prepared in no way I
researched nothing I showed up and
talked about what I thought
the you were um you were talking about
uh him coming and not being prepared and
the and about uh how is his opinion
changes and stuff the left doesn't have
a foundational opinion on stuff because
of the fact that it's power games
there's no more moral framework yeah for
example when uh that that woman came on
the culture War I'm not gonna say her
name yeah and uh because I'm kind of
tired of it but she said the show
appeals to neo-nazis and then 10 minutes
later or half an hour later told uh
actual Justice Warrior that he was too
right-wing for this show because the
show was moderate quite literally saying
random words for the sake of saying
random words well no it's they're
they're not random they're all designed
to undermine so I mean it's it's in its
own way a consistent moral framework if
it's counter to the right and in its
pursuit of like their own power I mean
James Lindsay talks about that a lot
it's not a double standard it's one
consistent standard if it helps me to
help my cause if it's for the pursuit of
power then it is good this is why
Lance's abortion thing broke down in the
way it did because he doesn't have a
real position on abortion he has talking
point and so I with an actual position
on limits of government individual
rights constitutional rights when does
Life Begin and have all these views
where I've had many discussions about it
trying to understand it you can ask me a
million one questions and I will give
you an answer or outrighteous be like
you know what I'm not I'm not so sure
about that I just don't know and I bet
you're willing to change your opinion if
you find out something that might go
contrary to your existing world I can
guarantee that Tim is willing to change
his opinion although I've noticed it
doesn't always happen right away
sometimes we'll argue and I'll say
something where I'm like damn I was I
was good I was true and then like it'll
be like three days later you'll be like
yeah you'll see what I was talking about
doesn't always happen right away thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time